[Musik]
die ära des könig bb scheint endgültig
vorbei zu sein scheint denn benjamin
netanyahu dem architekten und des
modernen israel weiß man nie netanyahu
hat in der israelischen politik eine
zentrale rolle gespielt und das land
länger als jeder andere gelenkt er war
premierminister von 1996 bis 1999 und
dann wieder von 2009 bis 2021 aber nicht
nur das baby wie er liebevoll genannt
wird leitete wenn einmal nicht
premierminister war auch zwei der drei
wichtigsten ministerien israels zwischen
2002 und 2003 war er außenminister und
zwischen 2003 und 2005 finanzminister
mit anderen worten auf die ein oder
andere weise hat mit herrn jahr auf fast
25 jahre lang in der israelischen
politik entscheidend mitgemischt sie gar
nominiert 25 lange jahre in denen das
land eine enorme transformationen
durchlaufen hat wir reden hier über so
bedeutende dinge wie den enormen
wirtschaftsaufschwung denen israel in
den letzten jahrzehnten erlebt hat seine
zunehmend klare position der
technologischen führerschaft im globalen
maßstab und seine offenheit gegenüber
der welt einschließlich einem
paradigmenwechsel
denn noch vor einem jahrzehnt denkbar
gewesen wäre ich meine damit natürlich
die etablierung diplomatische
beziehungen zu den arabischen
großmächten aber jede noch so schöne
geschichte hat nun mal ein ende
im juli 2021 sagte eine mehrheit adresse
dem israelischen parlament für die
ablösung von könig baby als
premierminister nach einem zähen
verhandlungsmarathon oder naftali
bennett zum neuen oberhaupt des
hebräischen staates gewählt
und das obwohl wenn jetzt hat alina über
sieben der 120 knesset sitze verfügt
stellst du dir also auch die frage was
genau steckt eigentlich hinter netanya
haus abschied und noch wichtiger
möchtest du nicht auch den neuen
mächtigen mannes nahen ostens und seine
mehr als bunte regierung kennenlernen
kann angst in diesem video verraten wir
alle wichtigen details darüber und
glaubt mir diese werden wir den kopf
verdrehen und am ende des videos wirst
du wohl eine ganz andere meinung darüber
haben ob die ära netanyahu wirklich zu
ende gegangen ist lasst uns also schnell
loslegen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es stellte sich heraus dass bei den
wahlen am 23 märz 2021 benjamin
netanjahus partei der liegt wieder
einmal jene kraft war die mit abstand
die meisten stimmen erhielt trotzdem hat
es könig baby nicht geschafft eine
parlamentarische mehrheit zu formen die
unterstützen würde er war nah dran aber
es gelang ihm einfach nicht das liegt
zum teil an mit vorwürfen die ihn auch
vor gericht gebracht haben tatsache ist
dass netanyahu in drei gerichtsverfahren
verwickelt ist weil 1.000 2.000 4.000
dem ersten wird eines betrugs oder
untreue beschuldigt weil er angeblich
zigarrenkisten und champagner von
geschäftsleuten erhalten hat insgesamt
werden die vermögenswerte auf 150.000 us
dollar geschätzt
dann gibt es noch den fall 2000 in dem
er beschuldigt wird einen deal mit dem
besitzer der meistverkauften
israelischen zeitung yedioth achronoth
ausgehandelt zu haben damit diese
freundlicher über ihn berichtet im
austausch dafür soll er regulatorische
vorteile für das medienunternehmen
versprochen haben und schließlich gibt
es noch den fall 4000 dem netanya und
beschuldigte wird den führenden
telekommunikationsunternehmen des landes
besichtigt um israel ebenfalls
regulatorische fähigkeiten gewährt zu
haben im tausch gegen positive
berichterstattung auf einer website die
vom ehemaligen vorstand der firma
kontrolliert wird netanjahu wurde daher
wegen bestechung betrug und untreue
angeklagt das sind die anschuldigungen
die auf dem tisch liegen und unabhängig
davon ob netanyahu schuldig ist oder
nicht sicher ist dass diese
rechtsstreitigkeiten sein öffentliches
image untergraben haben
trotzdem wollen laut umfrage nur 42
prozent der jüdischen und 56 prozent der
arabischen israelis dass babys seien hut
nimmt
wir sprechen also angesichts der
anschuldigungen nicht überwältigen
mehrheit und die tatsache dass es nicht
ein größerer prozentsatz war zeigt uns
in welchem ausmaß die israelische
gesellschaft über ihren langjährigen
führer gespalten war
die spaltung der israelischen politik
die enorme parlamentarisches betrug und
netanjahus unfähigkeit eine neue
parlamentarische mehrheit zu erreichen
war jedenfalls ein szenario das nach
taliban at wie kein anderer nutzte um
selbst eine spitze zu kommen aber auch
ja zu sein
es ist noch lange nicht klar wie solide
seine neue regierung wirklich sein wird
naftali bennett wird neuer
premierminister der acht parteien
allianz benjamin netanyahu stürzt acht
parteien koalition klingt ganz schön
wild nicht wahr und es sollte ganz für
bennet schon wenige wochen nach seinem
amtsantritt die probleme kriegen
israelischen parlament naftali bennett
verliert seine erste schlacht gegen
mittag die abstimmung zur verlängerung
eines gesetzes das die verleihung der
israelischen staatsbürgerschaft an
palästinenser die israelis heiraten
verhindert vergrößert die risse in der
fragilen regierung aber über all das
werden wir später sprechen
tatsache ist das projekt zusammen mit
ihr ihre lapis von der zentrums
liberalen partei sich aktiv der
zweitstärksten partei im parlament es
geschafft hat den wähler vor allem zwei
dinge zu verkaufen erstens dass israel
erneute parlamentswahlen um jeden preis
vermeiden muss da die israelis zwischen
2019 und 2021 preis viermal an die
wahlurnen muss denn so eine
parlamentswahl ist kein billiger spaß
die vier letzten haben kosten von
insgesamt 42 4 milliarden us-dollar
verursacht ja genau 4 milliarden und 240
millionen dollar in einem land mit kaum
neun millionen einwohnern sind wahrlich
kein pappenstiel aber der grund für so
viel begeisterung hat damit zu tun dass
israel das einzige land auf der welt ist
in denen es ein gesetz gibt das
automatische neuwahlen erzwingen wenn es
das parlament nicht er hat einer
bestimmten zeitspanne schafft einen
neuen haushalt zu verabschieden in
diesem fall führte tanja muss
unzureichende mehrheit dazu dass die
budgets ab 2018 immer wieder verschoben
wurden was dieses jahr neuwahlen
auslöste war in israel haben besonders
hohe kosten nicht nur wegen der schweren
sicherheitsmaßnahmen um die sicherheit
während es bald als zu gewährleisten
sondern auch weil der wahltag
automatisch als feiertag für
arbeitnehmer gilt und jeder
arbeitstätigkeit als überstunden mit 200
prozent des regulären gehalts zu
erwerben
[Musik]
und damit ein jahr wieder in der lage
war eine klare mehrheit nach der ersten
noch nach der zweiten dritten oder
vierten mal zusammen zu bringen war die
botschaft klar
zweitens seien die parteien die
oppositionsjahre stehen in den
gerichtsprozessen einfach eine gute
gelegenheit könig bb loszuwerden
aus diesem grund wurde eine der
seltsamsten koalition in der geschichte
israels auf den weg gebracht eine echte
mischmasch regierung die aus leuten
besteht denen man kaum zutrauen würde
zusammen auch mal ein paar minuten im
gleichen raum zu verbringen ohne sich an
die kurve so strengt wir reden hier von
acht parteien aller möglichen
ideologischen ausrichtungen und mit
einem regierungschef besten partei bei
den wahlen gerade mal sieben
abgeordneten mandate gewinnen konnte
doch wer ist nach talent eigentlich und
was könnte israel regierungschefs für
das land und die politik im ganzen nahen
osten bedeuten schauen wir uns das noch
mal schnell gleich als nächstes an
bennet der gemäßigte radikale taliban
erhalten diesen namen im hinterkopf denn
er könnte in den kommenden monaten für
viele schlagzeilen sorgen neue
israelische premierminister ist alles
andere als ein gewöhnlicher politiker
der so us amerikanische eltern ist ein
ehemaliger hightech unternehmer der
seine firma star für 145 millionen
dollar verkauft hat aber das ist noch
lange nicht alles was auf dem kasten hat
wenn nächste als junger mann in spezial
vor der israelischen armee gedient hatte
und trotz seines millionär status als
reservisten libanon krieg 2006
teilnahmen führte eine einheit von 67
kommandos das spezialkurs durch diesen
einsatz wurde wenn netanyahu
höchstpersönlich als neuer staatschef
rekrutiert damit gelang ihm der sprung
in die höheren etagen politik seitdem
und bevor er premierminister wurde war
unter netanjahus sechsmal minister sogar
der zwei wichtigsten ressorts wirtschaft
und tat was religion angeht so beginnt
er sich zum modernen ochsen judentum
einem zweig des jugendclubs der etwas
fundamentalistischer ist als die
derzeitige mehrheit in israel
aber das säkuläre und politisch und
sozial gemäßigter als die haare den die
ultraorthodoxen und in der tat ist der
erste premierminister der die ganze zeit
eine kippa trägt du weißt schon die
charakteristische jüdische kappe aber
jenseits der persönlichen themen ist das
was uns auf diese politiker meisten
interessiert logischerweise seine
politische positionierung
[Musik]
wenn jetzt selbst beschreibt sich als er
rechts von den jahren sowohl
wirtschaftlich als auch sozial
aber je höher im machtgefüge mit
aufgerückt ist desto moderater ist er
geworden
diese ganze vorstellung dass linke
vertreter sind und all dieser unsinn ist
inakzeptabel was baby seit ewigkeiten
gemacht hat die hundepfeife gegen diese
oder jene gruppe zu blasen das mache ich
nicht mit
ich bin recht als baby aber ich benutze
keinen hass oder polarisierung als
werkzeug um mich politisch zu promoten
naftali bennett aber die wahrheit ist
dass die spur die er den nachrichten
hinterlassen hat in alles andere als
moderat aussehen lässt zum beispiel ist
ein entschiedener gegner der sogenannten
zwei staaten lösung das heißt einem
arabisch palästinensischen und einem
israelischen staates er bezeichnete sie
gar als aufsicht der sicherheit vor
ihrem selbstmord für israel
und nein die sagte er nicht irgendwann
hinter verschlossenen türen sondern ganz
offen in bedeutenden medien wie der new
york times und cnn die alten modelle des
friedens zwischen israel und den
palästinensern sind nicht mehr relevant
es ist an der zeit die zweistaatenlösung
neu zu überdenken nachbar lieben es in
der new york times im jahr 2014
die ära dieser verhandlungen ist vorbei
die herangehensweise die wir seit 20
jahren versuchen ist eindeutig an ihr
ende gelangt auf taliban ebt auf cnn im
jahr 2014 das problem ist jedoch dass
ein alternativvorschlag zur
zwei-staaten-lösung nicht ein
vereinigter staaten alle wäre sondern
vielmehr errichtung einer art
dauerhaften protektorats für die
arabischen palästinenser natürlich unter
der kontrolle ist tatsächlich
verteidigte net auf die militärische
besetzung des westjordanlandes denn so
sagt er dieses gebiet wurde von israel
während des sechstagekriegs gewonnen
natürlich schlägt er in keinem fall vor
den fast drei millionen einwohner dieses
gebietes die israelische
staatsbürgerschaft zu gewähren
ebenso war er generaldirektor dessen
jascha council eine organisation welche
die interessen der israelischen siedler
in den jüdischen siedlungen im
westjordanland verteidigt denn ja der
neue israelische premierminister
unterstützt sie lohnen auf dem
territorium der palästinensischen
autonomiebehörde aber das ist nicht das
einzige thema bei denen ja kein
hat vor den mund im jahr 2018 sagte
bennett dass er wenn er
verteidigungsminister wäre eine
schulpolitik an der grenze zu gaza gegen
all jene arabischen palästinenser
umsetzen würde die sich an aggressionen
gegen israelische sicherheitskräfte
beteiligen und selbst auf die frage ob
dies auch für kinder gelten würde hat er
sofort eine sehr deutliche antwort parat
das sind keine kinder das sind
terroristen
wir dürfen uns nichts vormachen naftali
bennett im jahr 2018 gut mal ganz
abgesehen davon ob du zustimmt oder
nicht oder ob das viele kinder
tatsächlich von der hamas indoktriniert
und dazu abgerichtet werden israel
anzugreifen offenbaren dieses denken es
gehe nicht nur hart sondern ultra
unnachgiebig harte linie des neuen
premierministers territorial und
sicherheitspolitik sind jedoch nicht die
einzigen punkte auf seine agenda
denn genauso wie benett eine klares
beispiel für eine nationalistische
politiker ist ist auch hingebungsvoller
verfechter von freien märkten niedrigen
steuern der regulierung und dem abbau
von macht und privilegien von
gewerkschaften im entwurf des
staatshaushalts für israel auf den sich
die acht parteien koalition die ihn an
die macht gebracht hat geeinigt hat ist
ausdrücklich eine steuererhöhungs bremse
für 2022 vorgesehen in sachen sozialer
rechte ist er obwohl moderne auch der
dax relativ ausgeschlossen
so tritt er zum beispiel dafür ein dass
lgbt die gleichen rechte haben wie jeder
heterosexuelle
[Musik]
mit anderen worten israel hat einen 19
minister mit einer
wirtschaftsfreundlichen agenda erfahrung
im privaten und öffentlichen management
einer ruhmreichen karriere als offizier
in spezialkran schließlich echter coup
erfahrung und einen starten
nationalistischen schwerpunkt kurz
gesagt es ist so wie es sich selbst
definiert hat vereinfacht sprechen wir
davon dass rechts von netanyahu verortet
ist das heißt rechts von der
nationalistischen rechten aber nur weil
er premierminister ist bedeutet das
nicht dass er freie hand habt werdet
leitet eine der heterogenen regierungen
die wir uns vorstellen können eine
regelrechte frankenstein regierung warum
ich gerade diese analogie gewählt habe
nun was jetzt mal gut auf
[Musik]
frankensteins regierung nationalistische
rechte nationalliberale liberale mitte
zionistische sozialdemokraten grüne
linke und islamisten eine koalition aus
parteien die buchstäblich über das
gesamte politische spektrum verteilt
sind diese vollkommen zufällig
erscheinende mischung ist es welche die
neue israelische regierung mit sage und
schreibe 28 ministerien ausmacht was 28
ministerien erscheinen dir wie ein
ungeheurer moloch zu israelische
verhältnisse ist dies eine ultraschlanke
regierung der kenianer hatte zuletzt 36
minister unter sich so sieht es aus in
der israelischen politik jeder muss
seinen teil vom kuchen abbekommen keiner
bleibt ohne eigenen futtertrog und als
wäre das nicht schon chaotisch genug ist
die regierung darüber hinaus in zwei
unterschiedliche arten aufgeteilt in den
ersten zwei jahren wird bei
premierminister sein muss für die
restlichen zwei jahre ja ihren abschied
von der liberalen und säkulären
zentrumspartei erstattet wenn und ja
wenn es diese verrückte koalition
überhaupt so weit schafft denn du siehst
ja wir haben es hier mit einer riesigen
chaos maschinerie zu tun die mit einem
einzigen ziel in gang gesetzt wurde
könig baby aus dem auto werfen und in
dauerhaft von der macht fernzuhalten
kann das aber wirklich funktionieren nun
die wahrheit ist dass viele israel unter
aus experten wenn ich sogar die meisten
glauben dass diese regierung keine fünf
minuten überleben wird und das klappt
nie an die reihe kommt zumindest nicht
mit der aktuellen koalition das extrem
breites spektrum geradezu
antagonistische ideologien oder
ausrichtung der koalitionspartner aus
denen sich zusammengesetzt ist macht es
sehr schwierig ein konsens zu erreichen
besonders wenn es mal hart auf hart
kommt ich denke da zum beispiel an eine
weitere eskalation der gewalt mit der
hamas in gaza um die sollbruchstelle zu
finden müssen sie ja gar nicht lang
suchen in der neuen regierung sitzt also
stellvertretender minister für arabische
angelegenheiten ein israelischer araber
vertreter der vereinigten arabischen
liste kurzen partei
diese lehnt den zionismus als er die
grundlage der existenz israels als
jüdischen staat ab und ihre mitglieder
vertreten auch andere radikalislamische
positionen
wir sprechen von mansur aber es ist
schwer vorstellbar dass die regierung
weiter unterstützen würde falls diese
eine stärkere kontrolle über das
westjordanland durchsetzen oder im falle
erneuter terroranschläge oder
raketenbeschuss durch die hamas in gaza
hart durchgreifen wollte aber nicht nur
dass eines der politischen ziele von
abbas innerhalb der israelischen
regierung ist ist die staatlichen
subventionen für arabische städte und
glauben halt israel zu erhöhen was mit
dem netz befürwortung von jüdischen
siedlungen in version an land nicht sehr
kompatibel zu sein scheint mit anderen
worten die größte herausforderung für
die neue israelische regierung ist weder
die in noch die außenpolitik und auch
nicht die landesverteidigung sicherheit
oder wirtschaft nein
ihre größte herausforderung ist ihre
eigene existenz ihr fortbestehen als
selbstzweck bei net ist sich dessen
natürlich vollkommen bewusst aber als
kluger politiker weiß er diese tatsache
in viel schöner klingende diplomatische
worte zu packen
unser prinzip ist wir werden uns
zusammensetzen und das vorantreiben
wollen wir uns einig sind und es gibt
vieles wollen wir uns einig sind verkehr
bildung und so weiter und was uns trennt
werden wir beiseite lassen
naftali bennett premierminister von
israel doch die konflikte werden kommen
diese regierung hat kein politisches
projekt sondern nur die mission
netanjahu zu verhindern
zu allem überfluss verfügt sie nur über
eine hauchdünne mehrheit von einem
einzigen abgeordneten das heißt 61 waren
gegen und 59 für netanyahu auf den punkt
gebracht sind dies die charakteristika
der neuen regierung und des neuen
oberboss der israelischen politik und
verteidigung
es dürfte wohl uns allen klar sein dass
es mit dieser regierung in israel keine
sekunde langweilig werden weswegen wir
hier am ball bleiben werden und sich auf
dem laufenden zu halten
du hast uns doch schon abonniert oder
falls nein dann aber schnell ran als abo
und wenn wir schon dabei sind was denkst
du über den schritt mit anti netanyahu
blogs baby aus der regierung zu drängen
hat diese koalition eine zukunft oder
wird sie im chaos untergehen besteht die
gefahr dass sie das ganze land gleich
mit herunterzieht oder sind die
versöhnlichen töne über ein derart
breites politisches spektrum
orchestriert durch einen der
gewichtigsten um diplomatischen führer
ein hoffnungsschimmer für ausbildung und
ein abbau der ideologischen
polarisierung und denkst du jetzt wurde
die fakten über die neue regierung
kennst dass die ära netanyahu nach 25
jahren wirklich vorbei ist teilt eure
meinung bei uns und auch allen anderen
ich hoffe dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat es ja gibt uns mit einem
like teil der neuen freundin und es
nicht wie gesagt unseren kanal zum
abonnieren macht's gut shalom und bis
bald
[Musik]